oh i love how this rice looks
okay that was too much smoke okay fine
hi tasty i'm vishal from buzzfeed india
and this is how i cook rice in mumbai hi
tasty i'm gabi and this is how i make
rice in japan
hi i'm omar and this is how i like to
make rice in mexico city
today i'm going to make one of india's
most beloved rice
dish biryani i love biryani because it's
not just
a celebration of flavors in your mouth
but it is also
a highly practical one bowl meal now
let's get cooking
we have to start off with the marination
for marination
i have half a kilo of chicken here i
have sliced two medium onions i'm gonna
add it to the chicken
this gives that extra flavor to the
biryani so i'm gonna add these
fried onions about two tablespoons of
fried onion
pudina or mint is probably my favorite
ingredient because
you can add them to your biryani you can
add them to your chutneys
and you can also add them to your ethos
i'm going to add a bunch of mint leaves
enough to cover up your chicken now we
need to add
curd and it says it needs to be beaten
so i'm going to beat the skirt
i'm kidding just so that it's
gooey and nice and there you go half a
cup of
dahi or curd i'm gonna add one teaspoon
of coriander powder
so this is one tablespoon of chili
powder amazing
the color is finally coming up three
green chilies i have slit them
it's all going to go inside next it's
time for one of my other favorite
ingredients and that is
ginger garlic paste i'm gonna do one
tablespoon of ginger garlic paste
yeah you can add the salt according to
your taste gonna use my fingers my
fingers are clean
don't worry mix this whole thing
together
oh i can already smell the spices
i'm gonna leave this for three hours and
wait for the masalas to start
chili getting into the chicken and to
the nooks and crannies of the chicken
and the bones and then
we'll cook it while our chicken is
getting marinated i'm gonna take half a
kilo of basmati rice and soak it this
marshmallow rice has been cleaned
please clean your eyes the rice is
soaked so that it cooks
more easily it's been 20 minutes now i'm
going to boil this rice and cook it till
it's about
70 80 percent cooked i'm gonna take this
pressure cooker
because i want to make that really
separated rice so for that
we need to boil it if you pressure cook
it it has the risk of becoming
kind of pasty so we don't want that so
and i'm gonna add
my rice to it you can add water just
enough to
soak all the rice mix it i'm gonna add a
little bit of salt
half a tablespoon of ghee i'm gonna add
green cardamom
smells really good three cloves and i'm
gonna add half an
inch of cinnamon give it a nice mix our
rice is eighty percent cooked so it's
time to strain it
oh i love how this rice looks it's
already smelling so good i've spread the
rice out on this plate so that
doesn't become a cake in the pan so i'll
just set it aside for now you can take
a pot which has a thick bottom i've
taken 2 tbsp
ghee let it heat for a bit our ghee is
heated i'm gonna add our chicken
it's smelling really really good and let
this cook for about eight to nine
minutes
until the chicken is kind of tender and
then we are going to
layer it that's the most exciting part i
have a pan here
i'm going to add the first layer of rice
now it's time for the second layer which
is
our chicken our really really high
production chicken
another layer of rice now i'm going to
add a little bit of gravy to this
for that i'm going to use the pan in
which i make the chicken
and i'm going to add some water to it
add a little bit of milk
add some ghee to it we add curry pudina
mint leaves coriander i'm gonna give
this a nice mix
our fried onions mix it again yes
this gravy is looking really good i'm
gonna let it
boil for just a tad bit more and then
i'm gonna add it to the biryani
so this is the rice and the chicken
layered add
our gravy now on top of it
okay mix it a little bit so i'm gonna
cover our biryani
and we're gonna wait for it to cook for
about 15 minutes
so that all the flavors get mixed up the
rice and gulf song the flavor of the
chicken
that's when our biryani will be done i
cannot wait to try this
here we are this is our biryani i'm a
little nervous to taste this
smells really good like i would totally
pay for this so some biryanis tend to be
a little dry and it becomes really
difficult to eat them it gets boring
but this biryani i'm pretty sure you can
eat it all by itself
i'm so glad that chicken looks really
tender
i'm just gonna take the rice
really good spices are more subtle it's
not very hot
if you want it hot you could always do
some variations with the chilies and the
spices and everything
this person made for me is perfect
hi tasty i'm gabby and this is how i
make rice in tokyo nine years ago i
moved from mexico city to japanese
student university
i graduated i got a job i got an
apartment and i'm
just never left in this many years i've
eaten a lot of japanese food
and one of the things i really like is
yoda
you don't is you beef
and don rice bowl now there's actually
very kinds of don
for example maguro don which is tuna so
a tuna rice bowl
or there's katsu katsudon katsu is
deep-fried cutlet
it's also very delicious but today we're
gonna be making yuda
cause it's the one that is the most
comforting to me
first thing we're gonna do is the rest
i'm gonna be using
my lovely trusty beautiful rice cooker
it's just
rice and water that's it i put two cups
of rice with a little bit of water and i
just
press the button let it cook it's done
and the rice cooker will keep it warm
until i have to use it
so that's it simple thing ever this is
going to make our
beautiful broth now we're going to pour
our water
in here at the dashi mix this
very well and completely dissolve
once that's dissolved we are gonna add
everything
else except the onion for sugar medium
sake and soy sauce
we're going to mix them a little bit and
we're going to turn this on
and we want it to bring to a low simmer
this one you have the rice and then you
put the meat on top
and all that beautiful broth just kind
of like drips into the rice
it just gives it this very nice texture
i don't know why
it just makes me happy now that this is
starting to simmer
we're gonna put in low heat and we're
gonna add
our onion another little stir just to
make sure that everything
gets down there i'm gonna wait for 5-10
minutes
until the onion starts to like soften
and absorb all that
delicious broth for the main part we're
gonna add
the meat this is a very common kind of
cut in japan
as you can see super thinly cut so i'm
gonna add
all the meats here it's 200 grams
of beef that i'm adding in here
mix this so it cooks in the bread
we're gonna let this rot reduce and then
cook meat for another
10 minutes or so and that's gonna be it
our bread has reduced but there's still
quite a bit of liquid in there so it can
soak into our rice
we are done with this now we're just
gonna
put everything together take our rice
put it in our bowl place it in
here a little bit more we want to cover
the rice completely i think that's one
thing
that i love about you though is that
actually when they ever serve it to you
you don't see the rice underneath the
beef is placed in a way so that
you think there's only beef in there and
i'm gonna pour a little bit of the
sauce on top and that's it a delicious
udon now this is the most basic version
of
udon actually on top of this you can
also add things to it the most common
toppings are
pickled radish or a soft boiled egg you
can get creative with it
so let's try this baby
it does bring me back to university my
friends
2 am eating this no complaints still
really delicious
i'm very happy so that's it that's you
[Music]
then
today i'm gonna make a rosa la tombada
it's a typical dish from veracruz mexico
i really love this dish because it's
like a mexican paella
have a lot of flavors a lot of rice a
lot of seafood we're gonna
start we need to add in a saucepan a
little bit of
oil we're at our five tomatoes
and we need to put all our heat this is
basic
for many mexican sauces smoke
tomatoes and you have an incredible
flavor if you can see this is the color
and the texture
we are looking for and the tomatoes are
ready
this is time to blend our tomatoes
we're gonna put in here gonna have a
half
cup of water
we need to reserve this and now we are
starting to
make our arroza la tumbada the first
thing we need to do
is wash our rice we need to add two
tablespoons of olive oil
then two cups of rice combine the olive
oil and the rice
cook this rice until we have this golden
and beautiful color add
onion and 2 cloves of garlic i'm going
to keep
moving this rice if you can see the rice
is done and have this golden color it's
time to add
our tomato paste okay and cook for
another five
minutes we can add a little bit of salt
in this moment
this smells amazing and now this is my
favorite part of this dish we're gonna
add all the seafood
we're gonna start with prawns if you
don't have problems with
you can add lobster now we're gonna add
shrimps all our rice we're gonna add
clams
and we're gonna add pre-cooked octopus
this is a little chunks
to add in all your rice
i'm gonna add fish broth this is four
cups
in all your rice look at this
and this is all the flavor of our dish
this is a pasote
if you don't have a pasota you can use
parsley
but if you can have a pasote is this
the best flavor of our dish
and more salt and when need foil like
this
and this
and cook it for 20 minutes until
there is nowhere in our rice we finished
cooking the rice for 20 minutes at the
end we rested for
10 minutes more for half this delicious
and fluffy
rice and now is the best part is
testing this rice are you ready
look at this this is really delicious
has
all of this seafood smells amazing
has all of these colors i need to try it
the pasote all the seafood this is
really awesome
girls i remember this recipe
this is a delicious arroz a la tumbada
this is a very very delicious food for
all your family try this recipe and see
you soon in the next video
thank you so much for sharing this
experience with me don't forget to check
out me and my friends at buzzfeed india
and i hope you enjoyed this video thank
you for watching and i hope you enjoy
oh yes
[Music]
you